now the trade union congress is going to
hold a rally in london next month
calling for mass pay rises for workers
because of the cost of living crisis now
there were hints this week that the
government could do more possibly tax
cuts even the emergency budget that
labour's been calling for but if there
isn't more action could the unions be
squaring up for a summer of strikes well
we're joined now by the general
secretary of the tuc francis o'grady
thank you so much for being with us how
worried are you about the rising cost of
living and what that means for low-paid
workers in particular
i think everybody's worried they're
seeing
those price increases eating to pay
packets but also into pensions and
benefits and i think there's a real
sense that
the government needs to get on with this
now you know we know that millions of
working families are struggling we're
seeing the number of children in
absolute poverty increase uh electricity
and gas bills rising at 10 times the
rate of wages it's about time that the
government recognizes a living standards
emergency and they need to come back to
parliament with an emergency budget i
mean frankly there's so much talk on the
conservative back benches that we're
going to see another u-turn on this i
wish the government would just get on
with it
you i want to see more rises in people's
pay to help them at a time of course
when the cost of living is increasing
but is there a concern that that could
further stoke inflation andrew bailey
the governor of the bank of england has
said you know we do need to see a
moderation of wage rises and i don't
want to sugarcoat that it's painful but
we need to see that in order to get
through this problem more quickly do you
agree with that
england was wrong on this one the
governor was wrong uh all the evidence
is that prices are being driven by
increases in energy prices certainly not
wages which are set to fall in real
terms on the contrary people need help
now
and in addition if we suck demand out of
the economy then we're going to risk
that recession
uh coming ever sooner so what we need is
for the chancellor who i'm afraid
woefully failed working families with
his spring statement and i think
most people recognize that he needs to
come back with that whimful tax on the
energy companies that would provide some
immediate relief a real investment in
renewables so we tackle the root causes
of the problems with high energy prices
a boost in the minimum wage how on earth
people are supposed to survive on nine
pounds 50 an hour when in real terms of
course that's set to fall we need a a
real boost the minimum wage and fair pay
agreements across the board and and the
chancellor you know we've had enough of
lessons from conservative mps on
cooking or buying value brands i think
they are looking you know incredibly out
of touch with what most people are
experiencing people on low incomes are
very good at managing their budgets the
problem is those budgets are too tight
and of course it's bad for the country
too we've we've seen this government
fail to bring in an employment rights
bill to tackle low pay and insecurity
and that is costing the exchequer to the
tune of 10 billion pounds
in lost tax revenue and higher benefit
payouts it's bad economics it's a false
economy
and working and respect governments to
stand up for them and help them now not
in a few months time when it's too late
over the last 12 months the tec has
logged 300 disputes in different
industries which effectively illustrates
that people are challenging below
inflation pay rises
do you think we could see widespread
industrial action if more isn't done on
pay
look i think the government needs to
start listening to people and get back
in touch with the strength of feeling on
this
um yes of course unions exist to try it
and get better and fairer pay deals and
terms and conditions for their members
that's what they do and we have seen
that mood increasing in both the public
and the private sector
but um of course we've got that national
demonstration on saturday the 8th the
18th of june
where working people will be coming
together to protest and demanding better
but you know the way to deal with this
is for
the chancellor to get a move on come
back to parliament with that emergency
budget for employers to get around the
table with unions to negotiate fair
solutions we've seen profits recover
very well by the way i think um the
governor did belatedly acknowledge that
so that was the case
and we just need a bit of fair treatment
you know we we all want more money for
our public services we all want the
country's finances to be in good health
but it's a case of fairness here and i
think people feel very strongly that uh
the wealthy are not paying their fair
share of tax
that workers are being treated like a
cash machine hammered every time there's
a crisis we've had 10 years of this
don't forget over 10 years of austerity
pay freezes real pay cuts
and there's there's no more fat left to
trim
people are looking for help now
at the same time you know you mentioned
there there the rally coming up and
ahead of that rally your colleague dave
ward the general secretary of the
communication workers union has said
employers are out of control
i mean most employers are businesses who
are also struggling with the rising cost
of living aren't they like the rising
cost of of everything from energy bills
to
products and supply at the supply side
they're providing jobs for millions of
people is that really the kind of
language that is helpful
look i think there's clearly a mixed
picture um you know we have some very
good agreements with employers and we've
made some very good um pay settlements
but we've also got employers who were
hoarding cash who were paying fairly um
i think most people would agree obscene
increases in top pay in the boardroom
and you know as i say people just want
to see a bit of fairness but i think the
government can't walk away from this
i think most people agree that that
spring statement which included tax
hikes
which hit the lowest paid
and young workers hardest on national
insurance you know simply wasn't fair
they need to come back with an emergency
budget but rather than spinning it out
to the
summer or august as we're hearing in
some newspapers they need to come back
and do it now there are some ready-made
solutions that make sense including that
windfall tax
on
energy companies and let's not forget
that the oil companies said it would
make no difference at all to their plans
for investment they can afford it
and they should do it and the government
should get on with it
now i do want to ask you about the prime
minister's comments about working from
home i asked quasi-costa about them
early he said that he thought that
actually for some people it did reflect
their experience
the prime minister said my experience of
working from home is that you spend an
awful lot of time making another cup of
coffee and then you know getting up
walking slowly to the fridge hacking off
a small piece of cheese and then walking
very slowly back to your laptop and
forgetting what it was you were doing
do you think he's right
well it feels a bit ironic given i guess
the prime minister is the classic case
of somebody who always works from home
because he's based in number 10 and that
may be his experience
of grabbing coffees and wandering around
the kitchen but i think
again people deserve a bit of basic
respect i think people who work from
home work very hard
and this should be a matter you know for
unions and employers to sit down and
come up with sensible agreements i i
would have hoped that politicians facing
a living standards emergency had more
important things to be getting on with
than trying to interfere in day-to-day
industrial relations between civil
servants
managers and their unions
this week the government also announced
90 000 job losses among civil servants
and i think it's important to say you
know we're not just talking about what
the newspapers would call sort of pen
pushers
these are prison officers court staff
customs officers
immigration case handlers
are you worried that this is going to
damage public services and specifically
in what ways
well of course this this is you know
back to austerity and we saw how
austerity failed not only ordinary
people and families but it failed
uh the country in the end by holding
back growth and of course you know these
these are key workers who work right
through the crisis
uh important uh public services for all
of us that provide that safety net
uh that keep us safe
you know these are important jobs so how
on earth the government expects to be
able to shed 90 000 at a stroke and for
it not to
damage
communities in the country i i really
don't know so i think we need to
hear from them exactly what their plans
are but don't be surprised
that unions are angry and that
communities will be extremely angry if
we're looking to get hit again in terms
of
key public services that keep us safe
and just finally um you are stepping
down at the end of the year after a
decade as the first woman to hold the
job of tuc general secretary and i've
spoken to you many times you know over
that period and i'm just wondering you
know if there's any kind of reflections
you would give
on that decade in the job you know do
you think workers are better off now or
when you started and also what has it
been like for being
like a woman you know in the world of
work right at that moment and at a time
when obviously more recently there's
been lots of debate about um women in
the workplace as well
well i'm going to be keeping my
shoulders to the wheel for some time yet
i don't leave until the end of december
and i'm focused absolutely on you know
doing our bit uh to ensure that the
government and employers
face head on this living standards
crisis and give working people a fair
deal
um but i am proud of what we've achieved
and i think the real lesson is that when
we work together as a trade union
movement we can achieve a lot if you
think about the pandemic our wonderful
uh members in health social care
transport
refuse collection right across the piece
but so often they had to look to unions
to protect their health and safety they
didn't have proper ppe
we had to fight for the national
guidelines
and of course the furlough scheme
wouldn't have happened without the trade
union movement and you know ultimately
protected 12 million livelihoods at its
peak and
you know that
was designed to help the economy recover
more quickly too but you know to do that
in a way that channeled support through
people's pay packets is the best way to
sustain
demands in in local economies shops and
businesses so
you know i think we've got a lot to be
proud of on the equality front um you
know we are now a movement 50 50 men and
women uh we reflect
all society and every race every
religion every background and i'm proud
of that too because i think when working
people stand together when we're united
we can win
okay thank you so much for being on the
program always interesting to talk fans
are so great there
thank you